done i'm talking over the play harrison  shut up  and  he has hombert in this game we're  looking forward to the show very much my  son came derek cheetah would have made  that a ball  i'm sorry if it was a strike you  remember how we used to do that  can i do my derek jeter go ahead his  derek jeter a strike right down the  plate no movement on it whatsoever this  is what he would do he'd go  i swear to god like six times out of ten  he'd get a ball right so granted he's  one of the greatest who ever did then  he'd do the outside one oh he would lean  over  this he would lean over like it was a  foot outside  yes and then you throw it to him again  outside he hits it in the right field  thinking like oh that's way too far out  i can't hit that  genius i mean that guy was  he was incredible i don't hate  individuals i just you know if they're  great i can't i can't work up that level  even even yankees right no  there's a whole bunch of yankees that i  love i just hate them